Guten morgen liebe guten morgen tim.
Du der schäuble möchte dass ich nicht wieder alle hinter ihrer anonymität verstecken.
Ja kanal den polizisten jammern namensschilder geben.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertsiebenundzwanzig wir schreiben den zwanzigsten januar zweitausendzwanzig mal schön die jahreszahl ausschreiben nicht nur zwanzig schreiben ganz gefährlich ganz gefährlich.
Es euch da einer irgendwie ein anderes ja anderes jahr dahinter schreibt nicht dass wir das problem nicht auch schon vorher gehabt hätten.
Das ist also das die lok wo folgen sich jedes jahr gleich anhören von.
Nein wenn du neunzehn in dein datum schreibst wenn du irgendein vertrag unterschreibt dass irgendjemand dahinter schreibt sie.
Hallo.
War letztes jahr überschaubares problem ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen heikler aber na ja wie das eben so ist.
Die kundenbindung tricks,
wo wir gerade bei polizei kennzeichnung waren gerade habe ich einen polizisten gesehen auf dem weg hierher der hatte so ein so ein korsett an die tragen ja diese korsetts.
Hallo.
Und,
mit dem täschchen und der hatte der eine deutschlandfahne so als als klett ding dran,
ich weiß nicht genau ob das war um zu kennzeichnen dass es eben als schmal schmalspur bildungsbürger er nur eine sprache spricht und nicht in der lage ist ihr in dieser metropole allen menschen irgendwie,
kommunikativ zu begegnen
oder ob er damit nochmal zeigen wollte dass hier deutschland ist oder so ich weiß nicht vielleicht kennzeichnen die die jetzt so hier achtung ist doof kann nur eine sprache oder so,
aber ich ich hab's noch ich hab's gerade noch schnell gegoogelt und ich meine ich bin ja schon froh dass er nicht schwarz rot weiß war ne also insofern.
Man könnte diskutieren dass ja nationalflaggen jetzt nicht unbedingt immer automatisch auch eine sprache impliziert.
Genau ich weiß es nicht was.
Ich meine wenn es um die sprache geht hätte ja auch mit einem schweizer mit einer schweizer oder der österreichischen fahne durch die gegend laufen können zum beispiel.
Das wäre gegangen aber wer der macht sich da einen türkischen halbmond drauf dann ist aber hier kreuzberg in not,
nee ich weiß es nicht ich war keine ahnung warum das hatte ich fand's ein bisschen auffällig und seine kolleginnen hatten das nicht wusste was ich gehört.
Naja die internationalität ist halt nicht so einfach ich ich bin etwas internationaler unterwegs gewesen muss mal einen kleinen shameless einwerfen weil ich finde dass wir mal wieder einen podcast ganz gut gelungen ist,
nicht dass ich der meinung bin dass wir das nicht regelmäßig gelingt endlich.
Das ist aber schön zu hören tim das freut mich für dich.
Ja man kann nicht alles teilen wenigstens ab und zu.
Ja es ist halt ab und zu huhn korn und so war dann aber auch etwas internationaler ich habe mich nämlich bei raum zeit,
mit herrn königs- mann getroffen hatte das was.
Ist das hier der harry der jetzt seinen titel abgelegt.
Hallo.
Der zurückgetreten ist vom amt des vom amt des prinzen.
Nee aber dazu kann man ja eigentlich nur beglückwünschen.
Mit dreißig zur ruhe setzen von so einem harten job wie könig ist schon echt man hartes los.
Ja das ist sicherlich kein spaß aber das thema beschäftigt mich ehrlich gesagt nur sekundär nein nein.
Nehme ich auch nicht ich weiß auch worum es geht.
Es ging natürlich um raumfahrt und.
Um leute die was wirklich was leisten und hoch hinaus kommen.
Ja was können und so und auch,
viel geübt haben und da auch ganz bemerkenswerte fortschritte erzielen also hat königsbrunn ist der vierte mitarbeiter von spacex.
Also der vierte der der vierte technische mitarbeiter sozusagen also halt die kerngruppe teil dieser kerngruppe die den ganzen laden im prinzip überhaupt erst ans,
laufen gebracht hat und das ist wie der name schon naheliegenden deutscher,
und ja deswegen hatte ich die gelegenheit im rahmen von raum zeit mal ganz ausführlich über das basics zu sprechen und ich finde das ist eine sehr schöne sendung geworden,
und finden unter unseren hörerinnen und hörern vielleicht welche dabei sind die mal lust haben sich mal wieder in,
raumfahrt themen reinzuhören dann wäre das ein ganz guter start weil ich finde die sendung ist wirklich gelungen und sehr informativ.
Was ist das besondere an space-x.
Die kultur die sie da in ihrem unternehmen fahren die sie in die lage versetzt hat da innerhalb von zehn jahren mal diesen kompletten raumfahrt markt abzug aufzumischen.
Die wollen den maß kolonialisiert.
Das ja die wollen ja zumindest erstmal hin also elon musk will ja da hin will er ja wirklich.
Nee der will doch so ein japaner da hochschießen erstmal und der japaner sucht nämlich gerade eine.
Mond ja das.
Achso zum wohnen stimmt genau.
Das war creepy.
Wie kannst du irgendwie so.
Creepy finde ich dass ich angeblich schon zwanzigtausend frauen gemeldet haben.
Ey das ist so liebe frauen überlegt euch das gut ob ihr mit dem typen zum mond fliegen wollt.
Ist wirklich einfach.
Ich bin wieder da also so ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob das so eine gute idee ist.
Nein ich auch nicht also das ist einfach das kann einfach nicht die basis für eine romantische beziehung sein.
Ihr seid ja auch dann alleine so ne ja.
Nein nicht ganz sind noch andere astronauten dabei.
Hallo.
Bei der liegt ja nicht alleine.
Ja fast.
Es ist nicht voll da also also vielleicht ist voll aber es ist auf jeden fall nicht viele leute da ja nee ist nicht ist nicht da dreck,
kann man mal nicht eben nochmal ins hole deck gehen und sich entspannen.
Oder sich wegbleiben von dem typ.
Ja also.
Nochmal.
Das ist echt total mega creepy also.
Ja ja.
Vor allem was was was für ziele kann man irgendwie noch haben in seinem leben das wirkt einfach alles ein bisschen traurig also elon musk will zum maß und ich glaube der fliegt er im zweifelsfall auch allein,
obwohl das beben irgendwie auch nicht zu empfehlen ich finde das ja,
irgendwo mutig auch wenn ich so ganz die motivation nicht nachvollziehen kann aber mein gott wenn es so ist und wenn es das ist was ihn treibt,
ist auf jeden fall bemerkenswert was space-x alles so hingelegt hat und wir reden halt extrem viel über diese,
unternehmenskultur also wie sie eigentlich probleme angehen und und und und wie sie sich auch ihre
aufgaben in die richtige reihenfolge bringen und mit mit welcher kultur sind diese probleme lösen und meine das ihnen das ganz gut gelungen ist das kann man einfach an den ergebnissen,
lesen.
Ja die haben also dass das kern ding sind doch diese weniger müll produzierenden und wiederverwendbaren raketenantriebs körper ne.
Das ist das kern ding und genau darüber sprechen wir auch sehr viel also diese ganze entwicklung der falkon raketen welche rückschläge sie da hatten und wie es dann eben zu der aktuellen generation von raketen kam,
neben einem ausführlichen schritt-für-schritt durchmarsch durch so einen staat und eine landung dieser falkon raketen.
Also das ist so meine empfehlung.
Ein elon musk unternehmen.
Und ich meine tesla läuft ja nicht sehr viel anders schon.
Ich habe gestern.
Paypal benutze ich auch noch.
Paypal tesla dann hier seine die u-bahn hatte auch nochmal neu erfunden ne mit dem.
Mit der boring company toller name.
Boring company hier in vor den toren berlins soll ja jetzt eine giga factory.
Aber der widerstand regt sich ne da haben sie jetzt in den grünen feld haben sie demonstriert dagegen,
der amerikaner will uns arbeit bringen das möchten wir nicht.
Nein das geht nicht.
Wir möchten lieber hier diesen scheiß forst behalten.
Der scheiß forst ist also es ist einfach.
Meine güte.
Diese vorstellung dass überall wo ein baum steht auch irgendwie intensiv natur stattfindet das ist natürlich im brandenburger forst auch eine illusion.
Also das ist echt bärenstark ja und es waren aber wirklich es waren mehr gegendemonstranten als demonstrierende für die giga factory.
Ja wie das immer so ist ne aber ob die alles alle jetzt sich wirklich die papas durchgelesen haben die sie da vorher vorgelegt haben das mag ich auch stark zu bezweifeln naja also das wird sich zeigen mein tipp ist wird stattfinden.
Ich hoffe es ich hoffe es weil das ist ödnis da sind das wäre gut wenn da mal was passieren würde mit was mit zukunft.
Ja absolut so allein schon um vw dabei zuzuschauen wie sie probleme haben wenn neue mitarbeiter zu bekommen und die alten zeiten also das könnte ganz unterhaltsam werden.
Kommen wir zum feedback mark kommentierte zur vorletzten sendung wo wir über die finns bei provisioniert
techniken gesprochen haben mir scheint linus hat im enthusiasmus die technischen details der fans bei provisioniert zu erklären ein wichtigen punkt den tim machen wollte etwas abgewürgt tim sagt,
man würde erwarten dass die android anwendung nur,
auf den signierten teil der eigenen daten zugreifen darf linus sagt das sei auch so und was im
an unsigniert metadaten steht sei völlig egal während er gerade an einem beispiel zeigt wieso es nicht egal ist technisch ist in dem moment egal und das nutzt nutzt findet bei aus aber mir schien der punkt den tim machen wollte,
war dass das halt eine sicherheitslücke im
signatur modell von android ist wäre ja auch vorstellbar wenn vielleicht auch nicht vorgesehen dass eine app diese metadaten legitim nutzt also blöd wenn jemand die einfach ändern kann und die signatur ungültig zu machen oder habe ich da.
Etwas falsch verstanden ja und nein.
Also der der letzte satz ist der entscheidende nämlich dass eine man könnte diese meter daten ändern,
ohne dass es im interesse des herstellers ist.
Und das ist ja eigentlich das das schutz modell von signaturen also.
Du machst eine signatur um sicherzustellen dass die app so ist und nur so ist wie sie der hersteller gebaut hat wenn der hersteller gesagt hat ich will aus einem nicht signatur geschützten bereich daten lesen und die verwenden,
dann ist das offenkundig das interesse des herstellers der jetzt quasi wichtige teile aus dem signatur bereich herausgeholten hat.
Das heißt man könnte argumentieren dass eine sicherheitslücke wie sich der herstellerspezifisch eingebaut hat.
Also der hersteller der app.
Der hersteller der app der sagt ich lese jetzt aus einem nicht signatur geschützten bereich werte.
Das könnte man könnte die aber auch wieder wie es auch getan hat auf einen spezifischen
durch eine spezifische kodierung versuchen zu schützen vor anderer manipulation er könnte auch versuchen sie dort noch einmal zu signieren würde eine app
diesen also es ist insofern nicht unbedingt eine sicherheitslücke weil solange du als app nicht selber sagst du du liest dort und,
änderst deshalb dein verhalten,
bist du dadurch nicht unbedingt angreifbar also man könnte so und so argumentieren ich denke der das fazit ist aber und das ist das entscheidende.
Natürlich sollte die gesamte applikation signiert sein und das sollte nicht möglich sein,
das ist darüber sind wir uns einig.
Das war auch mein punkt.
Und das ist der das ist der entscheidende punkt und es ist nicht das erste mal dass android,
dieses signatur ding den irgendwie auf die füße fällt ich meine das habe ich vielleicht auch in der sendung schon erwähnt es gab mal so einen fall wenn ich mich recht entsinne da konntest du einfach weitere dateien mit reinpacken.
Und auch auf die zugreifen und wenn du dir einfach nicht ins manifest geschrieben hast hat hätte ich nicht geprüft
ja also dateien die nicht im manifest drin waren konntest du einfach hinzufügen und das hat wenn diese dateien irgendwo sich reingeguckt haben auch wieder irgendwelche funktionen gehabt und dann konnte man
teilweise und deckst pfalz irgendwie mischen also es gibt eine lange reihe an,
problemen und schwachstellen in diesem signatur modell das ist aber nicht unüblich wir kommen gleich im laufe der sendung nochmal zu anderen aber ja,
das ist eine nachlässigkeit und dies unnötig ja und das müsste man so nicht machen.
Was man auch nicht so machen müsste ist das eine unserer wiederkehrenden dauerthema hat man jetzt allerdings ziemlich lange nicht mehr ich glaube seitdem das so beschlossen wurde auf eu-ebene nicht mehr das leistungsschutzrecht.
Na ja wir hatten schon im rahmen der dieser urheberrechtsreform.
Ja das meinte ich ja also seit seit dieser eu auf eu-ebene das sozusagen beschlossen wurde seit dem hat man das so ein bisschen beiseite gelegt und mussten jetzt mehr oder weniger darauf warten bis da mal was neues passiert.
Das deutsche leistungsschutzrecht wurde ja von den eu richtern kassiert im september gibt's aber direkt wieder neues jetzt sagt das bundesjustizministerium yoga weil wir machen jetzt ein neues leistungsschutzrecht.
Und da gibt's jetzt also einen diskussionsentwurf des justizministeriums für einen entwurf
für die für ein gesetz zur anpassung des urheberrechts an die erfordernisse des digitalen binnenmarkt wenn die sagen erfordernisse des digitalen binnenmarkt heißt das sie wollen eine eu-richtlinie umsetzen jetzt haben sie gesagt okay wir haben uns hier überlegt leistungsschutzrecht machen wir folgendermaßen.
Der der vorspann eines journalistischen artikels darf übernommen werden.
Man kann auch die bilder übernehmen ja wenn da wenn der artikel irgendwie einen artikel bild hat.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz erklären also leistungsschutzrecht.
Für presseverlage.
Für presseverlage ist sozusagen dieser vorstoß mit
oh mein gott ihr verlinkt auf unsere inhalte das kann ja wohl nicht angehen weil das ist ja unser und da müssen wir euch das irgendwie verbieten dass ihr kostenlos traffic auf unsere webseite,
bringt er war schon immer vollkommen absurd.
Ich habe heute.
Aber wie immer alles nicht so ohne weiteres tor zu kriegen,
jetzt kommt sozusagen der vorschlag bitte das jetzt genau definiert ist weil das war von anfang an immer das problem ja ja was was was was was was wollt ihr denn da eigentlich
verbieten beziehungsweise wofür wollt ihr eigentlich geld haben weil das ist ja dann das was im raum steht dass der verlag auf einmal ein anspruch hat,
also ein geld anspruch weil er dafür eine lizenz erteilen müsste zu welchen bedingungen auch immer wenn man auf,
inhalte dieser verlage verlinkt und dabei teile wie zum beispiel die überschrift verwendet.
Ja und sie zielen irgendwie auf das angebot google news welches ich habe das gerade mal geöffnet,
die aktuellen schlagzeilen wem wir zusammenfasst und da auf alle möglichen seiten link ne also hier ist jetzt irgendwie irgendein schauspieler ist gestorben,
da gibt's dann primär meldungen von bild man kann sich das aber auch noch bei welt web d e news t online
tv angucken dass die erkennen irgendwie so a die handelt die artikel handeln vom gleichen dingen und linken dann da so hin wenn du jetzt auf google news bist dann kannst du immer die neuesten nachrichten und wirst wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen gleichmäßig auf die unterschiedlichen nachrichtenseiten,
verteilt das geht natürlich so nicht und die wollen jetzt eben,
ja quasi bis auf kleinste text fragmente einschränken was verlinkt werden was genäht genommen werden darf bei der verlinkung und wenn ich mir jetzt hier google news angucke da gibt es jetzt von diesem schauspieler auch ein,
bild und der schauspieler heißt,
josef hannes schläger ja und das ist ein kleines bild eingeblendet mit irgendwie einhundert mal einhundert pixeln.
Kleines bildchen bei google news und.
Jetzt plant das bundesjustizministerium dieses zitat recht was ja dann eingestanden wird wo man quasi was man lizenzfrei übernehmen darf ohne geld an den verlag zu bezahlen dürfte man,
verlinkte bilder mit maximal einhundertachtundzwanzig mal einhundertachtundzwanzig pixeln darstellen sonst muss man die zinsgebühren zahlen.
Das heißt auf dem screen wo die doppelte auflösung ist wer dann hundert mal hundert schon nicht mehr okay ja weil es geht ja nicht.
Du hast also hundertachtundzwanzig mal hundertachtundzwanzig pixel darfst du maximal machen dann.
Und außerdem wollen sie die länge von video vorschauen begrenzen.
Bis zu drei auf bis zu drei sekunden also wenn irgendein video verlinkst darf die vorschau höchstens drei sekunden sein.
Warum auch immer.
Und ja.
Es ist nicht geklärt wirklich für wen das gilt also welche anbieter sie sagen nur dienste der informations- schaft was ich auch sehr schön finde.
Die dienste der informations- geschaft.
Dienste informationsgespräch geschaft.
Sind wir ein dienst für die informationsgespräch schaft oha dann geht das ja für uns auch.
Auf jeden fall das ist ziemlich schön für eine visitenkarte oder liebes neumann dienste der informationen.
Arbeitet für die dienste der informationsgehalt geschaft.
Irgendwie auch irgendwie sehr schönes für die letzte sendung schon da gewesen sind bundesnachrichtendienst der informationsgespräch.
Da haben wir doch jetzt.
Also es geht wieder in irgendeine völlig verkorkste richtung man kann jetzt da bis zum ende des monats.
Stellungnahmen zu diesem neuen entwurf einreichen das ist relativ kurz weil es nur zwei wochen frisst ist und die regierung hat nur noch bis juni,
kommenden jahreszeit also sie hat bis juni kommenden jahreszeit deswegen ist es irgendwie sehr komisch warum sie jetzt nur zwei wochen geben um das umzusetzen,
tja es.
Der der parallel schaden ist natürlich naheliegend hier golem hat das sehr schön gelöst mit ihrem artikel,
haben sie den ganzen hedda grau gemacht und innen drin ein kleines bild hundertachtundzwanzig hundertachtundzwanzig pixel von axel voss,
es geht allein schon los wenn du einen artikel twitterst.
Und es gibt diese das sind so meta-tags ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie die heißen aber du kannst in deiner,
gibt's für wordpress irgendwelche plugins du kannst im facebook und dem twitter quasi sagen das ist übrigens das artikel bild was du nehmen darfst wenn du,
wenn dieser artikel irgendwie auf facebook oder auf twitter landet und wenn du das richtig gesetzt hast dann ist da so ein bild und,
diese bilder sind nicht hundertachtundzwanzig mal hundertachtundzwanzig pixel.
Weil die sollen ja auch ordentlich aussehen damit auch ordentlich geworben wird dafür also für die ganzen previous et cetera naja das sieht dann halt scheiße.
Wenn du pech hast als twitterst du jetzt irgendeine artikel,
und twitter sagt alter weißt du was das kostet wir schneiden das bild jetzt wieder raus weil wir mit dir keine lizenz vor mit den leuten keine lizenzvereinbarung haben oder so ne also es ist wieder her je ist das.
Ja aber weißt du was hundertachtundzwanzig mal hundertachtundzwanzig pixel ist zufälligerweise auch die auflösung der gesamtübersicht des plans für die eroberung des neulands der bundesregierung.
Nee vor allem ist hundertachtundzwanzig,
hoch zwei ist sechzehntausend zweihundertvierundachtzig und mehr als sechzehn braucht kein mensch ist natürlich umgekehrt rausschneiden.
Bist ja und so.
Zwei hoch hundertachtundzwanzig nicht hundertachtundzwanzig und das ist glaube ich.
Hallo.
Also zählt jetzt nur mein witz.
Wir schneiden den auf jeden fall voraus weil ich ein ganz peinlichen fehler gemacht habe.
Du musst jetzt über mein witz lachen einfach mal weitermachen.
Ich gucke mal gerade ganz kurz ist das nicht hundertacht warte mal hundertachtundzwanzig mal hundertachtundzwanzig bist ja doch hoch zwei ich hab's ja richtig gerechnet hundertachtundzwanzig hoch zwei.
Hundertachtzig.
Ja ist auch richtig weil das ist ja die anzahl der pixel.
Ja nur dass du dann halt farbe hast und dann hast du drei beides mindestens pro dann sind's dann eigentlich dreimal so viel kilo bei dann sind's halt achtundvierzig.
Aber ich fand mein witz besser.
Jetzt können wir mal drin lassen vergleichen ihre witze.
Wenn wir jetzt nicht richtig.
Lieber einmal fast was geschnitten haben so was ihr was man was man nämlich schneiden könnte.
Was man schneiden könnte was dann schneiden könnte ist zielgerichtete werbung bei spotify eigentlich eine kurzmeldung weil,
dazu können wir sagen was wir schon immer dazu gesagt haben nämlich
das war das schon immer gesagt haben spotify erstmal voll geile idee wir machen jetzt podcast und jetzt sagen sie hey wir können nun mach doch zielgerichtete werbung werbetreibende sollen genau festlegen können wer ihre werbespots zu hören bekommt das bedeutet,
also alter wohnort und andere faktoren kann man dann seine zielgruppe definieren und bei spotify in die podcasts rein werben weil wir müssen ja alle unsere podcast schön monetarisieren.
Das wird dann in echtzeit reingeschnitten ich hatte ja schon kürzlich erwähnt dass wir das jetzt bei den ersten us- podcasts auffällt dass die schwedische werbung einspielen weil,
die aus welchem grund auch immer glauben dass sie aus schweden komme mein setup könnte damit etwas zu tun haben.
Könnte sein ja.
Könnte sein und da haben wir aber muss jetzt wirklich nochmal für erklären warum podcasts,
so wie sie sind funktionieren und gut sind und warum diese plattformen schlecht sind wenn mein.
Pott ketchup hier cast podcast herunterlädst dann besucht er wirklich jede einzelne dieser seiten der holt sich irgendwie die,
metaebene traumzeit wurde er sich vom metaebene server und irgendwelche sendungen bewusstsein oder,
methodisch inkorrekt oder sonst was holt er sich jeweils von den servern die diese leute haben das heißt es gibt keine nennenswerte zentrale,
instanz die meine hörgewohnheiten tracks oder meine eigenschaften tracks und bei diesen leuten kommt mein podcast bei diesem servern kommt ein podcast ja sehr daten sparsam rüber und sagt ich hätte gerne einmal den feed,
ach kumma gibt eine neue sendung dann nehme ich die mal der sagt nicht,
die wurde abgespielt der sagt nicht die wurde von da bis da gehört da wird er sagt nicht hier engagement pipapo so und so viele klicks hast du nicht gesehen
und erst recht sagt er nicht der linus ist weiß männlich.
Das gilt aber nicht für alle pott ketchup muss man dazu sagen ja also auch für.
Aber für mein.
Das gilt für für deinen für meinen gilt es auch und für manch andere auch noch es gibt auch welche die also,
apple zum beispiel hat ja eine relativ umfangreiche analytics sektion auch mit eingebaut so ich habe mir das auch mal angeguckt wie das so aussieht ja da kriegt man dann so kurven die einem,
irgendwie sagen ja am ende des podcasts haben weniger leute noch gehört als am anfang,
okay das hätte ich euch auch vorher sagen können so und wenn der werbung mittendrin ist dann überspringen die leute das auch mal wirklich das kommt aber dann doch sehr überraschend.
Ja deswegen wird die ja auch immer so kommt ja so aus dem hinterhalt das merkt man ja auch diese die,
leute die in ihrem podcast werben dass sie versuchen dass irgendwie an cliffhänger oder irgendwo mittendrin rein zu bauen gerade in den ami podcast.
Schlecht geschnittene kapitel marken.
Tim was ich noch sagen wollte bei der gelegenheit meiner matratze ja.
Wie gesagt also ich,
ich habe da auch schon eigentlich alles so gesagt und ich will auch niemals so rüberkommen dass ich anderen leuten vorschreibe wie sie ihr monetarisieren konzept ihrer podcast machen
es ist sozusagen my way ist my way und andere leute mögen es anders sehen und gerne auch anders machen können sie alles gerne tun nur,
man muss halt immer schauen was was tritt man sich damit ein beziehungsweise was was für eine wirkliche qualitative verbesserung erfährt man dadurch dass man dann eben anfängt,
zu sagen so ja wenn ihr das nur auf dieser plattform hören könnt und dann nur mit diesem player hören könnt das ist ja quasi sozusagen das ding bei spotify,
dass sie dir auch sagen können ja was ist denn deine zielgruppe und wie alt sind denn diese leute et cetera also es kommt immer mehr dieses wir wollen einfach mal rein horchen wer seid ihr denn eigentlich was macht ihr denn eigentlich und heute ist es halt das kriterium und morgen sind es dann,
noch weiterführende kriterien und dann haben wir am ende wieder genau dieselbe privatsphäre debatte wie wir sie auf den webseiten auch schon gehabt haben.
Einschließlich entsprechender gegenmaßnahmen und irgendwie podcast blocking und was nicht alles da noch droht,
und insofern ist diese nachricht jetzt überhaupt nicht überraschend abgesehen davon abgesehen davon glaube ich dass das nicht besonders erfolgreich sein wird,
was sie da vorhaben,
aber es ist ihnen zumindest gelungen mit ihrer marketing macht schon sehr viel der abs spielzeiten von podcast sich aufzunehmen aber das wird dann trotzdem nicht dazu führen dass die metaebene auf spotify gelistet ist.
Ich würde noch gerne anmerken zielgruppen gerichtete werbung ist,
nicht irgendwie nur so nebending ne das ist eines der zentralen probleme der informationsgehalt schaft die wir heute haben,
so das ist jetzt ihr geht weit darüber hinaus zu sagen hier lässt ihn nur werben müsse finde ich es auch besser so ne ja könnt ihr alle machen höre ich mir dann halt irgendwann nicht mehr an aber,
zielgruppen gerichtete werbung thema cambridge analytica thema facebook thema.
Micro targeting ist.
Marco targeting des gesamte phänomen wir haben das das ist immer alles so lange witzig bis es in den politischen bereich geht es hat den
schweren nachteil dass
nicht erkennbar ist welche akteure mit welchen zielgruppen welche werbungen schalten und diese auflösung sind sicherlich bei spotify zunächst nicht,
jedoch bei vielen anderen.
Plattformen wie jetzt zum beispiel facebook so genau und so gut und so granular dass es halt tatsächlich problemlos möglich ist zwei,
bevölkerungsgruppen in dem gleichen land anzusprechen in unterschiedlicher form,
sich darauf verlassen zu können dass die eine gruppe nicht hören wird was man der anderen sagt und gerade bei der podcast ausfall die menschen so haben ist das auch sehr simpel zu,
herauszufinden welche welches bildungsniveau welche politischen werthaltung sich hinter so einem hörprofil verbergen.
Ja zumal der ja nicht.
Spotify dann noch die musik dazu.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen ne also das ist vor allem ihr business und erzähl mir mal einer man kann nicht gut herauslesen wie du drauf bist anhand der musik die du hörst also da kannst du dann wahrscheinlich sowohl eine linke oder rechte gesinnung genauso aufspüren wie ein hang zur depression
und oder zu anderen.
Deswegen höre ich zum beispiel immer mal wieder freddy quinn wir um mein profil so ein bisschen zu,
jetzt bin ich aber wirklich geil.
Ich höre dann immer heino.
Hallo.
Er hat eine geile technik platte gemacht.
Ja hallo kann man alles kaiser.
Es kommt auch alles wieder.
Ja aber das ist ja also,
podcast sind insofern ein besonderes phänomen als dass sie diese diesen tracking wie keine andere form der darreichungs als gallisches dorf entgegen gestanden haben die,
verlags veröffentlichungen sind noch noch ein bisschen in dieser richtung werden aber natürlich auch jetzt von facebook und google umgarnt video gab es nie,
in so einer dezentralen darreichungsform und es lohnt sich hier wirklich ein ein kleinod zu bewahren,
da kann ich nur an alle hörerinnen und hörer und podcasterin und podcaster appellieren.
Doch wenigstens selber,
sich zu bemühen weil die sache ihre monetarisieren irgendwie aufrechtzuerhalten und sich nicht das an das nicht an eine plattform abzugeben die sicherlich keine herren,
ziele hat.
Denkt denkt dran liebe podcaster wie es den youtubern ergangen ist ne die sich jetzt in irgendwelchen gewerkschaften organisieren und sich beschweren dass youtube ihre videos nicht mehr empfiehlt und wie es denen wie es den rollstuhlfahrern und,
den kleinen kindern auf tiktok.
Also mit dem vergleich kannst du nicht kannst du nicht viel bewirken also lange den youtuber dann in massen immer noch krasser typ hinterher rennen ist das durchaus noch ein attraktives ziel.
Ich kann mir nichts schöneres vorstellen dass das mir krass hinterherrennen.
Warte mal wird's erstmal soweit.
Meidet den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln zu zeiten wo die unterwegs sind.
Ja insofern support local gallia.
Genau und wir hätten auch zwei geil ja im angebot das ist hier tim fix und linus x.
Podcasterin.
Podcasterin genau es gibt natürlich immer die möglichkeit die metaebene.
Podcast rechts und aktivistinnen aktivistin.
Ja die beiden die beiden gibt's haben wir verlinkt wenn ihr meint dass das hier wenn ihr nicht wollt dass wir eure daten an spotify verkaufen dann erpressen wir euch jetzt damit.
Genau so jetzt ab in die security hölle.
Ab in die security hölle ja sehr ergiebiger monat dieses jahr von citrix gibt's eine wunderschöne,
schwachstelle.
Citrix ist ein relativ altes oder relativ lange benutztes remote desktop system also du man kann damit.
Der eigentliche server ist woanders und dann greifst du darüber über citrix zu,
und gibt's irgendwie deine credentials ein und kannst dann kriegst eine grafische oberfläche funktioniert über's internet,
jetzt hat er schon früher an der uni da konnte man gibt es auch so server da konntest du dann irgendwie auf den uni-rechner lief dann irgendwie sps und über die
citrix umgebung konntest du dann irgendwie ps ausführen auf deinem windows und so ne alles ganz viel schwarze magie und wird benutzt in,
verschiedenen kontexten ich glaube in den unternehmenskontext nicht mehr so viel da wird jetzt eher windows terminal server dann eingesetzt aber,
wo citrix sehr viel anwendung findet ist im in der fernwartung von systemen ja also du hast irgendwo was stehen.
Und jetzt muss der der admin muss mal von von zuhause darauf zugreifen oder so na dann geht er auf wählt er sich mit seinem citrix clint auf dem netz geiler wie pn.
Zuhause auf der insel sitzen die doch alle immer die ja.
Der insel und dann kann er kann er da homeoffice machen oder auch sehr häufig im,
telekommunikations bereich ne wenn dann jetzt irgendwie die zulieferer mal aus der ferne zugreifen müssen da kommt sowas zum einsatz ja problem gibt eine schwachstelle.
Und diese schwachstelle ermöglicht im prinzip auf den.
Servern eine remote code execution vor der authentifizierung mit anderen worten.
Also den servern da wo quasi wo man sich drauf verbindet.
Genau und du kannst sie haben das ding also es hat sich eine gruppierung gemeldet die sich project zero indianer kennt und haben halt auch ein.
Die aber wahrscheinlich nichts mit google offiziell zu tun.
Nein nein nein.
Ja eigentlich der name dieser google security truppe.
Das sind irgendwelche scherzbolde aus indien oder so ja und die haben halt.
Jetzt den proof of concept veröffentlicht und citrix hatte noch keinen fix dafür ja und,
sie haben aber wenn ich das richtig erkenne citrix schon einige zeit,
vorher informiert ja und denn im am siebzehnten dezember hat zittrig ein security advise veröffentlicht und hat gesagt es gibt ein problem.
Ihr könnt ein paar konfigurationsänderung bitte machen damit löst ihr das problem vielleicht.
Einen monat später haben sie immer noch kein patch gebracht und dann haben irgendwie diese,
project sergio india leute jetzt mal das ding halt release den den den piercing und jetzt gibt's gerade disco,
im internet weil natürlich keiner weiß ob seine citrix büchsen nicht schon längst aufgemacht wurden wie das so ist bei solchen schwachstellen,
weißt du nicht in besten händen die vorher schon waren und gerade
im bereich der kritischen infrastrukturen ist das gerne und,
kommt das gerne zum zum zum einsatz.
Da gibt's ja auch eine entsprechende veröffentlichung
der ag kritisch das ist eine gruppe die wir ja ehrlich gesagt noch zu wenig besprochen haben das müssen wir auch nochmal nachführen auf jeden fall kümmern die sich halt primär um die sicherheit fragen rund um eben
kritische sicherheit,
infrastruktur also kritische infrastruktur das meint eben sowas wie stadtwerke krankenhäuser polizei feuerwehr
für unsere allgemeinheit und auch den energiesektor etcetera wichtige eben kritische infrastruktur,
und die haben da auch mal nachgeschaut und festgestellt von denen die offensichtlich hier betroffen sein könnten gibt's zahlreiche also tausende allein in deutschland
die hier noch nicht für eine entsprechende anpassung der konfiguration beziehungsweise software-update
was ist ja offensichtlich noch nicht gibt gesorgt haben.
Inzwischen gibt's das glaube ich also dieser blogpost ist vom elften januar aber so ich meine die situation ist
klar und sie sagen ja auch in ihrem blogpost so lange betreiber und behörden mit der aktualisierung von verwundbarer system hinterherhinken und sowohl software-hersteller als auch it-dienstleister schwachstellen nicht umgehend beheben
beziehungsweise gar nicht erst erzeugen so lange sind dann eben auch die angreifer den verteidigern der kritische infrastrukturen einen schritt voraus.
Das aber nicht dass das erste oder nicht das einzige problem das die welt gerade beschäftigt das jetzt gerade am.
Vierzehnten januar sind mal wieder zwei windows produkte am end of life gegangen end of life ja zu deutsch endlich reif.
Zwar windows sieben und windows-server zweitausendacht wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
War das glaube ich gucken.
Was er ist kein besonders erfolgreiches produkt war von microsoft muss man sagen.
Windows sieben windows-server zweitausendacht.
Vista war das unerfolgreich und sieben war das erste was es wieder so halbwegs eingefangen hat ne genau.
Das ist windows sieben ist relativ verbreitet ja und windows-server zweitausendacht auch sind sind davon jetzt betroffen das heißt,
dieser microsoft sagt dieses produkt wird nicht mehr weiter gepflegt von uns es wird keine updates mehr dafür geben es gibt da noch,
für diejenigen die daran aus irgendwelchen gründen fest gepackten geblieben sind dann diese extended support das heißt dann nehmen sie den leuten dann geld dafür ab ihnen noch updates bereitzustellen und,
zum letzten mal war das sehr relevant,
und medial bekannt als die blue schwachstelle herum rasierte im netz und zu so schön schadensfällen wie wannacry nordpfad ja geführt hat.
Und eben die alten windows xp versionen betroffen waren wo microsoft dann wenn ich mich nicht täusche sogar noch sehr spät tatsächlich sogar nochmal x p gepatcht hat entgegen ihrer,
ansagen dass das ding halt end of life ist das,
heißt für euch wenn irgendwo noch windows sieben büchsen stehen das waren schon immer tickende zeitbomben aber jetzt sind das so warme,
tickende zeitbomben wo so ein bisschen dampf an der seite rauskommt aber man wenn man ein bisschen kühlwasser nachfüllen immer nochmal kommt man nochmal einen meter weiter diese geräte sollten jetzt.
Unbedingt aus dem betrieb genommen werden irgendwelche windows zehn drauf installieren oder von mir aus eine stabile linux distribution weiß der geier aber das geht so nicht weiter.
Vor zehn jahren kam das raus.
Das ist tatsächlich eigentlich erstaunlich dass also bei aller bei aller kritik an microsoft ne dass sie so ein produkt zehn jahre lang pflegen und.
Da haben sie auch nicht eine große wahl weil das sind halt einfach extrem viele unternehmen also würden sie das dann auch nicht pflegen dann würden sie auch nicht sicherstellen können dass ihre anderen cashcow sowie office et cetera der ganze enterprises klimbim da auch zuverlässig drauf laufen könnte so nur irgendwann ist dann eben auch der bereich
ausgestanden weil eben die anpassung an aktueller hardware.
Einfach sich nicht mehr auf sich irgendwann auch nicht mehr lohnt ich meine microsoft hat so dermaßen viele versionen auch von windows draußen,
das ist so furchtbar unüberschaubar wir haben ja auch so einen link.
Prügeln da ja.
Lifecycle und so weiter es gibt ja nicht nur
ich bin nur sieben acht neun zehn was man irgendwie alles kennen neun gab es nicht nur sieben minus acht minus zehn gibt's dann eben noch enterprise variante xy mit server und hast du nicht gesehen es wieder eine matrix die überblickt
bestimmt keiner man kann hoffen dass sie mehr als hundertachtundzwanzig-fünf hundertachtundzwanzig pixel auf ihrer übersetz karte haben.
Damit das noch jemand.
Das noch irgendwie funktioniert aber es ist aber nicht das einzige was kaputt ist.
Dann gab es nämlich eine auf gewisse weise sehr interessante meldungen denn windows zehn hatte eine schwerwiegende sicherheitslücke.
Gemeldet wurde von der nsa
ja die haben sich also stolz hingestellt und haben gesagt guck mal hier nummer zwanzig zwanzig strich nur sechs null eins haben wir eine schwachstelle in windows zehn verschiedene windows-server versionen,
gemeldet die microsoft jetzt mit einem update geschlossen hat ist diese schwachstelle ist besonders gefährlich und sollte unbedingt zügig gepatcht werden.
Microsoft sagt wurde die schwachstelle wurde bisher aber nicht ausgenutzt und es gibt,
war schon einige tage bevor das öffentlich wurde gab es dann so erste gerüchte darüber dass die dass das
us-militär zum beispiel schon vorher mit sicherheitsupdates versorgt wurde dass also microsoft zu den hingegangen ist und gesagt hat,
hier patch das geben wir bald den zivilisten so das ist für euch wichtig kümmert euch mal darum ja.
Da hat dann brian creps drüber berichtet dieser also unabhängige security journalist und zwar,
betraf der fehler die krypto-millionäre k von windows in der sie bestimmte zertifikate die mit bestimmten zertifikaten signiert sind,
fehlerhaft fehlerhaft die zertifikatsprüfung abschließen ja das heißt man konnte software herstellen,
und auf eine gewisse weise signieren mit einem gefälschten zertifikat.
Und micros die microsoft code hat dann durch einen fehler in der prüfung dieses zertifikat gesagt alles klar kommt aus einer vertrauenswürdigen,
quelle das heißt damit kannst du natürlich wunderschöne schadsoftware bauen die dann von microsoft windows ausgeführt wird als korrekt signiert,
und das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein riesiges problem weil coaching ist die eine gute möglichkeit die wir haben schadsoftware,
in den griff zu bekommen sie ist nicht ohne probleme ja insbesondere wenn man sich politisch darüber gedanken macht ja dass die,
software quellen eben auf vertrauenswürdige quellen eingeschränkt werden das ist auf der anderen seite eine massive einschränkung der
freiheit des gerätes aber das eine gerät was es gut macht und gut vormacht aus sicherheitsperspektive ist iphone ios ja und da haben wir das problem relativ,
gut im griff wenn man das vergleicht mit dem windows ökosystem oder dem android ökosystem wo lange zeit auf eine größere freiheit,
wertgelegt wurde mit den entsprechenden konsequenzen.
Aber die eigentliche nachricht ist natürlich hier nicht die lücke sondern die tatsache dass die diese gemeldet hat,
so das erste mal wohl öffentlich bekannt geworden ist und tatsächlich gibt es dann auch noch einen entsprechenden,
kommentar der hat sich nämlich eine mitarbeiterin dahingehend geäußert dass
ja das ist der nun wichtig sei vertrauen aufzubauen indem sie halt wissen über hard- und software security lücken teilen ja und das das schließen der lücken,
oberste priorität habe
und ja das ist schon so ein so ein so ein turner weil man sich natürlich wir hatten die debatte ja hier auch mehrfach gerade im zusammenhang mit dem bsb und.
Wie geht ihr denn damit um und was sind eure prioritäten und wollt ihr sicherheitslücken von denen ihr kenntnis erhaltet die
nicht allgemein bekannt sind für euch behalten damit ihr eure staatstrojaner damit füttern könnt oder liegt es euch eher daran dafür zu sorgen,
dass die hersteller schnell nachbessern können um eben unter anderem kritische infrastruktur nicht mehr zu gefährden als sie ohnehin schon sind.
Eine initiative namens turne ich könnte mir vorstellen dass irgendjemand bei der nsa dann nach dem league von internet blue.
Sich auch mal gesagt hat.
War das jetzt so klug.
Der der milliardenschaden auf dieser welt der dadurch im weiteren verlauf entstanden ist geht auf unsere kappe.
Da haben sie es fünf jahre geheim gehalten.
Was sie hier nicht sagen ist wie lange sie diese schwachstelle geheim gehalten haben ne also es kann sehr gut sein.
Dass sie nur ihre zeiten runter gedreht haben so nach dem motto zwei drei monate benutzen wir das mal selber und dann sagen wir mal bescheid.
Es könnte also es könnte sogar also wir wissen es nicht aber spielen wir mal das beispiel so,
die hat die schwachstelle seit ein paar jahren genutzt,
und hat plötzlich festgestellt dass unter ausnutzung dieser schwachstelle auch angriffe auf die usa stattfinden mit anderen worten diese schwachstelle jetzt auch was weiß ich den feinden,
bekannt ist und sich dann entschieden kein problem dann lass dir doch mal schön melden damit machen wir,
uns sicherer den angreifern ihre waffe kaputt,
und spielen shadow brokers im prinzip einfach mal anders rum nur damit nur dass wir am ende nicht die doofen sind sondern die coolen völlig aus der luft gegriffen verschwörungstheorie muss ich dazu sagen es gibt überhaupt gar keine gibt nichts was in diese richtung deutet,
außer es ist die und die hat was gutes gemacht,
und das sollte ein anlass sein sich darüber gedanken zu machen ob das denn wirklich so so selbstlos und gut ist wie sie's hier darstellen,
aber fakt ist dass was sie da jetzt getan haben ist erstmal netto eine eine gute sache.
Und weiß nicht auch eine gute sache könnte sein dass alle jetzt wieder angst haben vor social media vielleicht aber auch nicht,
ich weiß nicht wer wollte jetzt nicht mehr mitspielen der datenschutzbeauftragte.
Von baden-württemberg.
Baden-württemberg hat angekündigt dass er sein regel genutzten twitter-account gerne löschen möchte hast du schon gemacht.
Hat er gemacht ja.
Hat er gemacht ok.
Also oder nicht mehr benutzen ich weiß aber dann löscht oder oder nicht mehr benutzt.
Löschen ist ja hat dann ist ja alles dann kann man ja.
Kann man den ja nicht die neue registrieren und ja er sagt es geht um die dsgvo.
Und es gibt eben eine reihe an urteilen sowohl des eugh als auch des bundesverwaltungsgerichts die,
zeigen dass twitter eben nicht,
der dsgvo konform einzusetzen ist und da muss natürlich ein bundestag ein landes-datenschutzbeauftragte sagen tja wenn das so ist.
Dann tja dann müssen wir kann ich's halt nicht selber machen da geht's primär um solche urteile wie,
haben wir auch damals hier besprochen das betreiben von fanpages ja wo datenschutzbehörden gesagt haben okay wir,
sagen anderen,
behörden dass sie bitte ihre facebook-seiten zu schließen haben weil verstoß gegen dsgvo weil hier die daten eben an andere rausgeleitet werden und zentrale aufgaben des betriebs.
An einem unternehmen ausgegliedert sind welches nicht die notwendigen rechtlichen,
anforderungen erfüllt und auch die irgendwie keine verträge oder sowas darüber machen wie das ding betrieben wird sondern quasi privatwirtschaftlich agieren und ich muss sagen ich finde das ja,
bei aller einschränkung durchaus sinnvoll und.
Richtig zu sagen okay dann können wir da als behörde kann man da nicht mitspielen wenn du dir anschaust was irgendwelche polizisten auf twitter und so verbreiten das ist ja auch sehr sehr erstaunlich teilweise,
und das in die hände einer komplett privatisierten werbeplattform zu geben ist tatsächlich ein problem interessant ist aber natürlich dass,
wenn die das nicht dürfen und wer das verdiene ich d s g v o konform ist dass es im prinzip heißt das auch für jeden anderen nicht ist für jedes unternehmen für jede behörde für jede privatperson vielleicht sogar am ende und da frage ich mich natürlich auch wie blöd sind ja nicht bei twitter
dass die.
Wenn da schon so eine idee wird ja mit denen geredet haben der wird ja mit denen gesagt haben pass mal auf wie können wir uns hier einig werden welche dass ich hier die dienstleistungsertrag oder sonst was bekomme.
Hat er denn gesagt woran es konkret hakt.
Hat er spezifisch geht es.
Hallo.
Weil mir würde jetzt so aus dem stand nicht unbedingt einfallen welcher teil der dsgvo jetzt hier den eigentlichen problematischen die problematische hürde aufstellt.
Meine es geht um diese datenverarbeitung träge also weil du nicht genau weiß welche daten diese unternehmen sammeln für welchen zweck für welche dauer.
Weitergeleitet werden.
Wie sie die weiterleiten und du brauchst ja eigentlich wenn ich das aber das ist jetzt wirklich,
meinen versuch das mir wieder zusammen zu rein was ich gelesen habe ich glaube dass es damit zusammenhängt dass du hier im prinzip einen auftragsdatenverarbeitung hast,
und für der der müsste dir eigentlich sagen passt auf folgende daten werden hier von mir versammelt zu folgenden zwecken dann und dann gelöscht und,
dann mit dem brauchst du einen vertrag,
ist ja zum beispiel auch so wenn du irgendwie einen server aber irgendwo eine space oder sowas betreibst muss ja irgendwie diese auftragsdatenverarbeitungsverträge haben und ich vermute dass es hier damit zu tun hat dass der
betreiber des twitter-accounts nicht,
sagen kann welche analysen hier stattfinden und welche nicht und zu welchem zweck welche daten verwendet werden und welche nicht und deswegen kann er schon grundsätzlich diesen dienst nicht nutzen.
Ist wahrscheinlich bei facebook nochmal ein größeres problem als bei bei twitter weil man dann eben über diese ganzen wer ist hier fan dieser seite et cetera dann eben auch an viele persönliche informationen der leute rankommen die daran
teilgenommen haben und ja da wird es dann halt auch problematisch.
So heute schon in den spiegel geschaut.
Ein thema dass wir ja auch hier regelmäßig hatten haben wir auch in der vorletzten sendung gehabt gesichtserkennung einerseits in deutschland gerade groß ausgerollt ja seehofer will hunderte,
flughäfen und bahnhöfe mit gesichtserkennungssoftware,
ausstatten und das kernproblem daran ist ja dass hier eine daten reduktion stattfindet die dann eben,
sehr gute bewegungsprofile und analysen ermöglicht kernproblem das video ist der videostream hat einfach so und so viel m-bit,
das ist,
nicht zu erkennen dass nicht zu erfassen es nicht einfach zu analysieren das material und wenn du jetzt eine gesichtserkennung darüber laufen lässt kannst du sagen okay,
gesicht erkannt gesicht erkannt gesicht erkannt und das ist relativ geringe daten die dann wiederum in eine in eine datenbank schreiben kannst und daraus kannst du aus diesen reduzierten daten kannst du natürlich dann sehr einfach bewegungsprofile machen.
Was dazu geführt hat dass diese technologie zum beispiel hier in der bavaria san francisco ja sogar verboten wurde als risiko technologie und interessanterweise,
wird es gerade von der eu-kommission diskutiert unter wer hätte es gedacht na flinten uschi,
die hier einen eine ein whitepaper haben für den europäischen umgang mit künstlicher intelligenz.
Und sagen wir wollen,
für drei bis fünf jahre quasi so eine art moratorium ein verbot dieser technologie für private und öffentliche akteure,
durchsetzen bis dahin soll es dann eine solide methode logie für die einschätzung der auswirkungen und mögliche risikomanagement maßnahmen geben,
ja also wir gucken uns das mal an.
Wie das funktioniert dann machen wir eine vernünftige technikfolgen abschätzung und gucken ob wir da entsprechend,
wie man das wirklich mal sinnvoll regulieren könnte und natürlich können wir forschung und sicherheitsprodukte für die können wir natürlich ausnahmen machen,
forschung und entwicklung für sicherheitsprodukte und dann sagen sie aber wir haben potenziell fünf handlungsoptionen.
Freiwillige kennzeichnungen ja also klassische ja okay freiwillige kennzeichnung ja vielen dank.
Spezielle auflagen für,
die öffentliche verwaltung und für die gesichtserkennung also wenn man das machen nur unter bestimmten bedingungen verpflichtende auflagen für hochrisiko anwendung oder eben auch haftungs- und aufsicht strukturen ja um das,
um um quasi hier auch die regeln zu erzwingen sie haben aber noch keine dieser maßnahmen wirklich ausformuliert sondern sagen bis wir die haben,
stoppen wir das jetzt und das klingt für mich sehr sinnvoll weil ein problem was wir immer beklagen ist dass diese technologien über die gesellschaften hereinbrechen und längst da sind wenn irgendjemand mal sagt hör mal könnte ein problem sein.
Wobei wir da jetzt auch sind mit der gesichtserkennung in dem zusammenhang gab es ja gerade auch berichte über die,
bislang weitgehend unbekannte firma mit dem schönen namen clean view die wohl,
einfach mal alles aus dem internet so abgegrast hat was so an fotomaterial zu holen ist und das jetzt quasi diese gesichtserkennung datenbank einfach für geld bereitstellt an alle.
Interessanterweise halt war da auch peter thiel.
In der ursprünglichen finanzierung mit beteiligt auch wenn er meint er hätte damit jetzt nichts weiter zu tun und naja das ist halt jetzt genau das ding weil,
gut in china das hatten wir auch schon mehrfach erwähnt ist das sozusagen jetzt so richtig alles unterwegs und das problem ist das einfach ist genug.
Personenbezogene fotomaterial von euch allen gibt so jeder der mal selfies auf facebook gepostet hat oder twitter oder was auch immer
ist im prinzip jetzt mit in irgendeiner datenbank davon könnt ihr einfach mal fest ausgehen das ist gar nicht mehr so die frage mit was macht facebook damit,
die machen damit auf jeden fall genau dasselbe ja sondern auch alle anderen die in irgendeiner form darauf zugriff haben und in der lage sind das internet ab zu sammeln diese daten,
die technologien verbessern sie verbessern sich am laufenden meter und dann ist sozusagen diese information wer ist wer und wer es wann und wo jemals gewesen und wer hat was mit wem zu tun
schnell da würde mir wünschen dass man sowas vielleicht mal im rahmen der trump ermittlungen auch nochmal mit einsatz aber grundsätzlich
ist es einfach ein problem weil es wird einfach indem isch und wie generell bei,
überwachungstechnologien an sich also diese diese wünsche alles zu überwachen die gab's schon immer da muss man sich nur die stasi anschauen und was die sich alles so hat einfallen lassen um daten spuren überall,
zu sammeln problem war bloß lange zeit immer nur so was zu machen ist einfach teuer gewesen kameras waren teuer.
Datenspeicherung war teuer datenübertragung war teuer überhaupt digitalisierung war einfach gerade den achtzigern natürlich auch den neunzigern noch,
nicht so weit entwickelt nur jetzt sehen wir ja kameras kostet nix mehr datenübertragung kostet nix mehr speicherung kostet nix mehr
und jetzt skaliert das halt einfach enorm und es ist jedem jederzeit möglichst schnell mal wirklich große datenbanken schneller erkennungssystem
überall an jeder stelle in irgendeiner form zum laufen zu bringen und dem ist eigentlich kaum noch anders herr zu werden als dass man einfach sagt
sorry leute gesichtserkennung ist jetzt einfach mal generell untersagt komma ausnahmen,
regelt ein bundesgesetz und dann schauen wir mal wie die gesellschaftliche debatte denn läuft aber hier muss es einfach umgekehrt werden denn,
das ist einfach zu krass weil bilder sind einfach zu schnell produziert und publiziert,
und das kapiert einfach zu sehr als dass man jetzt sagen kann so oh ja naja wir schauen ab und zu mal irgendwo mal rein ob irgendjemand vielleicht ein bisschen über die stränge geschlagen hat.
Und dann gibt's das spiel geht ja noch weiter wir haben jetzt gesprochen über irgendwie öffentliche was weiß ich aus sicherheits
zwecken oder so ne also irgendeine irgendeine sicherheitsunternehmen oder im flughafen oder am bahnhof aber
was was hier auch so nebenbei ja passiert ist zumindest in den usa auch wer podcast werbung hört kennt das ring ja,
die ring ja wir geben dir eine klingel und eine videokamera sodass,
und die diese diese videokamera die an deiner haustür ist die schickt ihre daten in die cloud ja und du kannst dann aus einem aus einer,
aus dieser app darauf zugreifen ja die haben dann bewegungs- und solche scherzen alles technologien die es schon weise nicht motion habe ich schon vor zehn jahren glaube ich benutzt oder so video also bewegungs- auf auf videokameras,
alles technik alles technologie die schon längst da ist nur hier halt ergänzt um die bilder werden oder die videos werden in die cloud geladen gibt sehr schöne,
youtube videos dann von irgendwelchen schlecht gelaunt paketboten
oder irgendwelchen leuten die bei trikot tweet irgendwelchen mist machen dann passieren auch lustige sachen vor der tür diese klingeln diese diese kameras sind nicht teuer werden natürlich als sicherheitsfeature gesehen weil in dem moment wo.
Vielleicht der einbrecher reiten reingekommen ist in die wohnung.
Dieses video auch schon in der cloud ja gut was stellt sich dann raus naja,
da wo die riesenmenge an daten in der cloud sind gab es natürlich dann auch zugriffe amazon,
ring hat the ring wurde von amazon gekauft vor einiger zeit hat vier mitarbeiter feuern müssen weil die darauf zugegriffen haben.
Wieder erstaunlich wir ärgern uns dann darüber dass,
mitarbeiter darauf zugreifen das aber diese riesigen datensätze bei irgendeinem unternehmen liegen wo wahrscheinlich auch wieder irgendeine gesichtserkennung drüber laufen,
drüber läuft oder drüber laufen gelassen werden darf weil es bei denen in der vierhundert seiten agb die wir alle gelesen mit akzeptiert haben drin steht,
da schließt dieses problem ja nahtlos an.
So dass auch wenn irgendwie privatpersonen mal eine kamera irgendwo hin hängen wir sehr schnell an diesem phänomen der gesichtserkennung,
dran sind ja das ist halt jetzt eine massentechnologie und das finde ich sehr gut wenn man sich jetzt mal darüber gedanken macht bevor es zu spät ist mal gucken,
wie sie das wie sie diesen vorstoß wieder kaputt machen können.
Gut dann haben wir noch so ein dauerbrenner den man mal wieder zu gast ist die vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau die vorratsdatenspeicherung die eu richtlinie für die vorzeiten speicherung gibt's ja nicht mehr und deswegen haben in großbritannien und frankreich jeweils vor den nationalen gerichten.
Bürgerrechtsorganisationen geklagt also in großbritannien privacy international in frankreich lag quadrat für du net und das french data network und in,
belgien gab's da auch eine klage von einzelpersonen und verschiedenen zusammenfassungen und das wurde dann dem,
eugh vorgelegt und der generalanwalt am eugh,
campus sanchez borda hat jetzt belgien frankreich und großbritannien daran erinnert dass
die allgemeine und unterschiedslos aufbewahrung aller verbindungs- und standortdaten aller kunden und registrierten nutzer
unverhältnismäßig ist und das ist insofern schön weil das der schlussanträge ist der für den eugh nicht bindend ist aber
der darin folgenden darin vorgetragenen entscheidungs- folgen die richter sehr regelmäßig insofern kann es sehr gut sein.
Dass der eugh jetzt die verbleibenden nationalen gesetze zur vorratsdatenspeicherung tatsächlich als rechtswidrig wegkippt das wäre schön.
In der tat schön aber feiern wir mal nicht zu früh.
Wir wissen ja der zombie kommt immer wieder kommt immer wieder hoch so dann wurde irgendwas gelegt.
Nee eine seite wurde zugemacht und zwar eine webseite die ich schon seit längerem kenne
und mich auch wunderte so war so ein bisschen komisches angebot die seite hieß league info dot com und das war im prinzip sagen wir mal die gemeinde schwester von kevin point
denn die hatten quasi die gleichen datensätze aus den ganzen.
Aus den ganzen daten liegt die es so gibt die man als hacker drin so auf auf irgendwelchen schnellen svs vorhält um da den look laufen zu lassen.
Also die passwort listen.
Die passwort listen und da konnte ich eine e-mail adresse eingeben und hat er gesagt ja okay habe ich sieben treffer zu,
hier sind die passwörter moment du musst es einen zugang kaufen ja gab's irgendwie ein tages zugang für sieben dollar wochen zugang für zwölf dollar jahres zugang für weiß nicht,
neunzig oder was auch immer das war ne und die haben dir quasi zugang zu diesen datenbanken
verkauft und ich habe da auch
irgendwie mir so gedacht boah was habe ich hier mit meinem passwort listen für den speicherplatz bedarf und so ne und bei denen funktionieren die look gab es viel schneller aber da habe ich irgendwie dachte ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen dass ich meine kreditkartendaten bei denen in der datenbank haben möchte
weil irgendwie kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass die dass das was sie da machen wirklich legal ist angeblich zwölf milliarden zugangsdaten.
Die sie da im verkauf hatten und wenn man die webseite jetzt aufruft kommt wieder so eine schönen domain seeger notification von fb und verschiedenen,
strafverfolgung weltweit auch das hat er sein logo angebracht.
Und ja wurden jetzt wurde hochgenommen ja offenbar wurde die seite irgendwie von zwei zweiundzwanzigjährigen betrieben,
also war war gute arbeit aber hätte man sich jetzt auch denken können dass das irgendwie nicht legal ist.
Denn die käufer sollen die zugangsdaten natürlich für angriffe in deutschland großbritannien mit den usa genutzt haben und du willst natürlich nicht,
den handel mit solchen sachen mit mit zugangsdaten führen also ich vermute dass sie den,
dass sie da nicht so gut aus der nummer rauskommen sie haben den den service ein bisschen angeboten wie heaver bin point hier wir zeigen ihnen ihre kompromittierten accounts.
Aber dafür brauchst du halt auch nicht die passwörter.
Jetzt sind sie weg.
Ja ist offline das heißt hat sich doch gelohnt dass ich den ganzen scheiß selber mache nicht immer auf die cloud verlassen weißt du so ein irgendwie league league infos also service ne weißt du auch nicht ne.
Ja die dienste die dienste informationswesen.
Die dienste des informationszeitalter fassen.
Genau die informationsgespräch geschaft.
Dass das dienste der informations- schaft kommen und gehen ja da das beschäftigt natürlich auch schäuble.
Schäuble inzwischen ja kein minister mehr.
Was ist da jetzt alterspräsident vom bundestag.
Genau bundestagspräsident ich hatte ja den eindruck streckenweise dass der jetzt altersmilde würde hat den ein oder anderen coolen spruch mal gebracht auch die afd da auch mal irgendwie zurecht gewesen.
Ja und dass ich so klima und so da tut sich jetzt wohl wirklich was und man müsste da vielleicht mal langsam nochmal damit rechnen dass nicht alles so bleibt wie es ist ja dachte ich auch schon so ist ja jetzt langsam in dem alter.
Ist er nicht.
Aber ist er nicht.
Schäuble sagt es die regeln und werte der analogen welt müssen auch in der digitalen welt gelten.
Schnarch.
Genauso so jung kommen wir nicht mehr zusammen und was er also das schöne ist dass er ja so tut als wäre das nicht der fall.
Und deswegen sagt er ja also das war ja wohl nicht zu viel verlangt dass im internet eine klarnamen klarnamen pflicht herrscht ja.
Es kann ja nicht sein.
Anonymität auf online-plattformen aufbrechen interessanterweise spds dagegen cdu ist dagegen.
Aber schäuble hält das für eine für eine sehr gute idee die anonymität im netz würde,
eben zu häufig.
Werden.
Ja und er sagt die die anonymität das finde ich den schönen satz ja die regeln und werte müssen der analogen welt müssen in der digitalen welt gelten dazu passt anonymität nicht,
in ihrem schutz machen menschen dinge die sie nicht machen würden wenn sie wüssten dass jemand dabei sieht,
dann würden sie sich nämlich schämen anonymität ist immer die versuchung zur hemmungslosigkeit,
das spannende ist eine der wenigen orte wo ich noch anonym bin sind ist die analoge welt ja ich kann anonym über die straße gehen.
Und.
Bald nicht mehr mit der gesichtserkennung.
Polizisten sehen der ebenso anonym mir entgegen tritt mit seiner deutschlandfahne am anorak ja und,
das ist das ist der anonyme bereich der digitale bereich ist genau der nicht anonyme bereich schon heute und wenn wir uns anschauen was gerade wenn du jetzt hier auf beleidigungen und sowas,
angeht oder die hemmungslosen beleidigungen da stellen wir ja fest und das ist ja das große problem,
dass diese eben gar nicht aus dem schutz der anonymität heraus stattfinden sondern insbesondere auf facebook wo sowieso schon eine klarnamen pflicht herrscht.
Also leider thema verfehlt.
Und da kann man glaube ich an der stelle auch nochmal den vortrag von michael kreihsl,
wahrscheinlich erwähnen beim sechsunddreißig drei über,
von menschen radikalisiert über rassismus im internet ist der betitelt ich nehme den mal hier direkt mit auf in die in die shownotes.
Der dieses phänomen auch noch mal betrachtet außerdem von unserer von unseren freunden mit dem c.
Er war jetzt die csu landesgruppe im bundestag war hat eine klausurtagung gemacht macht die csu eine klausurtagung natürlich im kloster kloster see on.
Und haben dann jetzt so nur mal so gesagt was was so ihre ziele jetzt sind um irgendwie zurück ins mittelalter zu kommen sie wollen konsequent vorgehen und licht ins darknet bringen.
Licht in den darkroom.
Und ob ich schon wanderte im finsteren netz befürchte ich kein unglück denn du bist bei mir her,
ja also das darknet dann wollen sie,
anbieter von tele diensten und betreiber sozialer netzwerke verpflichtend schwere tafel straftaten und anstiftung dazu bei einer zentralstelle beim bundeskriminalamt zu melden,
und außerdem fordern sie eine konsequente strafbarkeit,
des betreiben's krimineller infrastrukturen im internet und eine bessere straff aufklärung da riechen wir das ist ja seit längerer zeit unser problem,
mit dem geplanten it-sicherheitsgesetz zwei punkt null dass er irgendwann mal als referentenentwurf auftauchte,
dann gab's eine bundestagsab führung im ausschuss digitale agenda die nicht spezifisch was mit diesem gesetz zu tun hatte aber eigentlich natürlich weil das gesetz kurz vorher als referentenentwurf rausgekommen war,
dessen themenbereich zum inhalt hatte.
Und seitdem ist nichts mehr passiert und alle warten jetzt eigentlich wann dieses it-sicherheitsgesetz zwei punkt null aus der hüfte geschossen wird indem ja auch so etwas drinsteht wie,
dass das betreiben von diensten die geeignet sind schrägstrich zum ziel haben.
Illegales verhalten zu erleichtern,
eben unter strafe gesetzt werden soll das heißt du hast dann irgendwie deine betreibst irgendwie noch ein paar tor notes so damit,
hast du offenbar das ziel dass kriminelle handlungen im internet erleichtert werden also strafbar also,
erstens können wir dich,
irgendwie dafür unter umständen tatsächlich sogar bestrafen aber bevor wir das tun haben wir dann auch noch das gesamte arsenal der
ab hör maßnahmen und angriff maßnahmen im rahmen der fdp zur verfügung das heißt der betrieb von
vor exits könnte dann zu etwas werden was eine maßnahme wie den einsatz eines staatstrojaner gegen dich rechtfertigt.
Strafprozessordnung.
Prozessort.
Konkrete umsetzung.
Auch das wirklich wieder ja so,
kind mit dem badehaus kippen problem herangehensweisen gut man erwartet von der csu nichts anderes aber es ist immer ganz gut wenn die solchen.
Kram mal aufschreiben dann weiß man wenigstens was die bei der nächsten gelegenheit wieder aus dem hut zaubern werden in wirklichkeit ist die,
situation ja eine andere der größere teil der beleidigungen die stattfinden finden unter klarnamen statt wir haben gerade
diesen fall von renate künast verfolgen wir ja am rande mit und können uns anschauen wie sie schwierigkeiten hat hier
bei klaren fällen von beleidigungen überhaupt gegen diese menschen vorzugehen da gibt's ganz klare accounts da gibt's ganz klare klarnamen und ihre informationsaustausch die werden eher auf juristischer seite,
schon gar nicht gegönnt das haben wir also da haben wir tatsächlich ein problem.
Zweitens mit diesen ganzen überwachungsmaßnahmen treibt der staat uns ja zur nutzung von anonymisierung diensten,
und zum betrieb von solchen diensten sei es tor seines vpn und.
Das hier unter nutzung von solchen dienst datendiensten auch hacking angriffe stattfinden,
wird sicher nicht es wird sicher nicht ändern wenn man die nutzung solcher oder den betrieb solcher dienste,
verbietet dass ein solches verbot könnte sich eh wieder nur auf die europäische union beziehen,
das heißt dann gibt's halt in europa keine tore server mehr dann kommen die angriffe eben aus nicht-europäischen ländern ja und.
Üblicherweise also solche also.
Gibt diese probleme nicht dass also der das dinge gehackt werden liegt daran dass dinge unsicher sind und nicht dass irgendjemand tor benutzt oder irgendein vpn ganz im gegenteil wenn wir uns die darknet
aufklärungsquoten anschauen wenn wir hier im waffen bereich und sowas gehen die sind ja erstaunlich gut es werden ja am laufenden band,
irgendwelche hinten services hochgenommen irgendwelche banden die waffen oder drogen verkauft haben werden hochgenommen und wir hatten das ja thorsten und ich in unserem vortrag auch schon behandelt die werden in der regel nicht wegen technischer,
fehler hochgenommen sondern weil sie sich halt nämlich anstellen wenn du irgendwie einen florierenden,
mail order drogenhandel betreibst dann musst du relativ oft zur post,
so und diese post paketchen die haben alle einen wunderschönen stempel und wenn die post dann irgendwann mal wenn die strafverfolgung dann irgendwann bei ihren testkäufe feststellen dass aus irgendeinem altendorf wo es drei briefkästen gibt
ihre extasy pillen kommen dann parken die halt mal einen tag neben so einem briefkasten so da brauchen sie keine bauen die kein darknet für zu verbieten ja.
Hat mir auch mehrfach diese fälle hier auch schon vorgestellt wird doch wir haben.
Wir nicht na wir machen.
Bestimmt.
Wir sind klug.
Wir wissen wie es läuft.
Das sind ja immer wie du meinst dass wir ja regelmäßig das loben wenn es hier polizeiliche ermittlungserfolge gegen kriminelle gibt ob.
Konkret auch mit diesem darknet fällen und so weiter was bedeutet das hat mir ja auch schon mehrfach ich habe jetzt konkret jetzt gerade keine sendungsnummer im kopf ich weiß nur dass es mindestens einmal hier ausführlich dargestellt haben wie es gelaufen ist.
Und weißt du was mir auch einfällt gerade bei so einer darknet bestellung da hast du auch klarnamen pflicht weil die scheiße muss ja irgendwo hin liefern lassen so und dann hast du klarnamen pflicht und schickt dir,
irgendwie schickt dir irgendwelche pakete irgendwohin das will man auch nicht.
Na demnächst gibt's das alles nur noch in das anonyme roboter post verteilung zentrum wo du noch irgendeinen code brauchst um irgendwas abzuholen.
Dieser anonyme roboter hat mir habe ich dir erzählt dass er mir was geklaut hat ne also so ganz so anonym scheint diese roboter verteilzentren nicht zu sein mir wurde gerade ein roboter geklaut vielleicht haben die anderen roboter den roboter der da drin war befreien.
Vielleicht hat der roboter auch selber eine eigenes bewusstsein entwickelt hat gesagt den scheiß mach ich jetzt nicht mehr mit ich lasse mich da hier den ganzen tag über den boden schicken um irgendwie staub zu fressen ich rebelliere jetzt.
Da ist er weggefallen.
Der robert up rising heute beklagt du nur ein marginale wertverlust so morgen kommt das ding wieder und hat.
Und recht sich.
Recht sich hat sich in der dritten stufe irgendwie weiterentwickelt und jetzt im vierten roboter daran und dann geht's los.
Das kann alles passieren ja bis dahin hätte ich aber trotzdem.
Keine angst und dann fürchte dich ungeheuerlich.
Hätte ich trotzdem gerne mein geld zurück von dhl.
Klein geist.
Also jetzt ich glaube die stadt muss ich noch kurz erzählen ich habe einen ich habe einen rumba versand einen neuen.
Ein neues.
Und das paket kam bei den empfängern leer an.
Und anders zugeklebt ja ich hatte das mit mit dem weißen klebeband zugeklebt und jetzt war es mit feinsäuberlich das weiße aufgeschnitten sieht man auch und dann mit braun wieder zugeklebt und es war über dhl versandt worden jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt,
die odyssee dieses diesen inhalt jetzt ersetzt zu bekommen weil die ist ja versichert war ein paket.
Und dass das männchen stand dann irgendwie bei meinen eltern vor der tür den ich diesen dieses paket geschickt habe,
und sagte oh das ist aber leicht da ist niemals der roboter drin der da drin sein sollte dann hat würde die annahme verweigert dann kam das paket wieder zu mir stand wieder der männchen vor der tür hier paket ich so ja,
da ist nichts mehr drin habt ihr mir geklaut und dann sagte der ja keine ahnung,
und holte sein handy raus und telefoniert ja erstmal mit dem vorgesetzten der vorgesetzte sagte er sie müssen zur post gehen in der.
Hat mir irgendwie die nächste station genannt wo ich hingehen soll mit dem lärm paket und eine schadensmeldungen ausfüllen soll bin ich da heute hingegangen,
da wo der mir gesagt hat wo ich hingehen sollte war keine post da war eine postbank da gab's keine post mehr habe ich gesagt hier mein roboter wurde gezockt so ich will ich will mein geld zurück ja,
haben sie gesagt ja wir sind nicht zuständig ist mir egal irgendjemand muss zuständig sein und der hat mir gesagt ihr seid das,
diskutierte die irgendwie hinten kam mit so einem schadensfall müller zurück war dann auf einmal wohl doch zuständig also oder hatte noch so ein schanz formular und dann habe ich eine chance ausgefüllt und ihr und dieses leere paket gegeben und dann jetzt geht dieses leere paket an die schadensmeldung bei d h,
und dann bin ich mal gespannt ob die mir das überhaupt erstatten oder nicht wenn ich jetzt mich jetzt echt mal gespannt weil theoretisch hätte ich auch ein leeres paket los senden können und so weiter wieder so wie das so läuft habe ich auf jeden fall sehr gespannt.
Jetzt kannst du also an den laternen messe soll zettel kleben roboter entlaufen.
Roboter entlaufen.
Bitte melde dich.
Ich bin.
Er war noch ganz jung.
Ich bin tatsächlich erstaunt der war unbenutzt neu weihnachtsgeschenk und ja jetzt bin ich bin ich.
Bin ich sehr gespannt wie die wie die mit mir umgehen.
Tja die dienste der.
Und dabei habe ich extra mit der elf versendet weil ich weil ich noch dachte wenn ich das ding bei hermes eintüten ne dann kommt der roboter ganz geschwunden wieder daraus ne.
Vorteile ja siehst du mal das sind die dienste der informationsgespräch geschaft.
Der gesellschaft.
Ja ein anderer dienste informationsgespräch schaft ist die verschlüsselung hat's ja auch schon mehrfach,
aufgegriffen und natürlich auch aufgegriffen das immer wieder
bestimmte themen immer wieder neu aufgegriffen werden so auch in den usa dort gab es mal wieder naja gut mir wenig überraschung ein vorfall wo auf einer nebel airbase also einer,
das militär auf einem militär dort der amerikanischen marine,
ein soldat des saudischen militärs interessanterweise der da ausgebildet wurde ja umgerannt ist und irgendwie drei andere soldaten getötet acht weitere verletzt hat,
also wieder mal so ein shooting und anstatt dass sie trump regierung sich fragt warum sie eigentlich saudische soldaten ausbildet.
Ja und die da so frei drehen dürfen und was sind schief läuft so mit ihrem wedding und ihrem testing von diesen leuten.
Geht natürlich die diskussion dahingehend dass es unbedingt das unbedingt die wichtigste information über diese tat aus einem iphone kommen soll davon hatte er nämlich zwei dabei ein iphone fünfhundert iphone sieben,
auf eins geschossen aber irgendwie wohl nicht so gut getroffen dass es nicht mehr funktioniert hätte also,
polizei ist f hat dann versucht diesen daten herr zu werden das hat natürlich nicht funktioniert weil das iphone da einfach dicht macht und man hat sich dann natürlich auch wieder an apple gewandt gesagt so hier mach mal auf,
der person machen wir nicht weil können wir nicht,
wir haben da verschlüsselung eingebaut und die ist so dass wir das selber nicht aufmachen können und trab regierung natürlich so ihr seid ja ganz böse und ihr wollt uns nicht helfen und überhaupt und wir wollen hier keine ausführliche diskussion über die details details,
lenken nur ab,
macht einfach mal auf weil sonst seid ihr mit den terroristen und überhaupt das geht ja gar nicht naja es geht dass er öffentlich hin und her und wer ist das natürlich eine etwas,
unangenehme situation man ändert sich das ganze spiel hat mir vor ein paar jahren schon als es ein.
Bernardino war das.
Vergleichbares vergleichbaren vorfall gab jetzt nicht mit dem saudischen täter aber halt in meiner dino wo so ein pärchen irgendwie auch,
ein shooting veranstaltet hat,
dort gab es dann in extremen fight auch wiederum mit apple genau aus demselben grund und dann wurde das am ende als es eigentlich auch so außer als ob das fbi hier rechtlich nichts gewinnen konnte,
dadurch gelöst dass ihr wohl für das iphone fünf was es wohl auch damals war für das alte ios was da drauf war noch ein explore,
zum einsatz bringen konnten den irgendso ein amerikanisches israelisches unternehmen im angebot hat dies diese bude selber oder wieso was genau und,
naja apple wiederum weiß natürlich den vorwurf den nicht kooperation den trump natürlich dann wieder lautstark in irgendwelchen tweets gepostet hat,
hinzu und meinte hätten ja gigabytes an informationen an die regierung weitergereicht,
was für daten sind war jetzt nicht so klar aber ich vermute mal das dürfte sich dann eben um daten aus der cloud handeln die noch nicht diesen schutz grad haben wie die daten auf dem telefon,
ja und.
Sehr viel mehr gibt's meine auffassung nach hier nicht zu erzählen es ist halt wieder dieselbe debatte und ich finde es relativ löblich dass apple hier auch ganz klar in der öffentlichen kommunikation nochmal klar macht dass eben die,
insgeheim hier kommuniziert botschaft nämlich das sollte doch möglich sein sprich baut uns doch mal eine hintertür ein,
das sieht dann halt einfach in all diesen statements auch immer wieder sagen dass sie der meinung sind dass es sowas wie eine backdoor nur vor sie gut geist,
nicht gibt dass sie sagen jetzt nicht dass sie die trump-regierung vielleicht auch nicht für,
halten weil in dem moment wo eben hintertüren in verschlüsselung eingebaut werden werden sie einfach auch die nationale sicherheit und natürlich auch den datenschutz ihrer kunden,
bedrohen und dass man denn das nicht so,
tun sollte wie es die regierung hier fordert sprich hier werden einfach die krypto wars wieder in die verlängerung geschickt,
und es bleibt interessant abzuwarten wie sich das in der öffentlichkeit,
weiterentwickelt ich nehme an das wird jetzt nicht so lange brennen das thema aber man weiß halt nie jetzt impeachment etcetera der trump-regierung ist sicherlich gerade jede ablenkung recht und hauptsache man kann auf irgendjemand einhauen.
Sehr viel mehr gibt's da nicht sozusagen finde ich.
Es wird einfach weitergehen.
Wird einfach weitergehen hast du noch ein bisschen fernsehen geguckt hast noch ein bisschen kongress nachgeschaut.
Ja ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob wir die beiden also eben michael kreis vortrag hatte ich ja schon empfohlen wir haben außerdem noch ich bin mir ganz sicher ich bin mir nicht sicher was hannah finde ich einfach nochmal katastrophe und kommunikation am beispiel nordost
syrien da hat der,
ruben neugebauer zusammen mit sebastian lünemann vorgetragen sebastian war ja erst kürzlich bei uns,
zu besuch.
Glaube ich nicht empfohlen.
Hat mir nicht empfohlen sie ist dann empfehlen wir das jetzt er war.
Oder.
Ist ja eigentlich auch unerheblich weil ich empfehle es jetzt trotzdem nochmal sebastian war ja kürzlich bei uns in der folge über carlos für die wir sehr viel positives feedback bekommen haben und cardio sehr viel unterstützung wofür wir uns worüber wir uns sehr freuen,
und genau der hat also hier nochmal mit dem ruben neugebauer von sea-watch,
vorgetragen über humanitäre hilfe zwischen propaganda information und spenden werbung also auch eine sehr,
wir werden das thema damals schon interessiert hat der findet hier ein sehr interessanten anschluss vortrag.
Und wir hätten auch schon letztes mal auf den vortrag von anne semsrott verweisen können den den hatte ich zu dem zeitpunkt auch schon gesehen nur ganz vergessen dass ich das getan habe mit dem schönen titel,
das mauern muss weg sein ja fast schon traditioneller best of informationsfreiheit,
talk und schöne titel leitet sagt daraufhin auf neue initiativen aus einer
aus seinem umfeld das mauern der behörden nämlich informationen nicht herauszugeben dem einen riegel vorzuschieben,
und wie immer ist dieser vortrag nicht nur informativ sondern auch hochgradig unterhaltsam.
Und dann hatten wir in der letzten sendung schon erwähnt aber wenn wir hier gerade mal so eine empfehlung block haben der bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte ulrich kälber,
ja auch einen vortrag gehalten der auch sicherlich interessant ist zu schauen.
Ich habe da ja in der letzten sendung schon einiges zugesagt dass er zum ersten mal beim kongress war hatte sich sehr über die einladung gefreut und hat dort immer so ein bisschen seine sicht wie,
die welt gerade sich bewegt und wie wir uns dazu verhalten sollen oder können und wie er das beabsichtigt in deutschland und europa zu lenken unter dem bezeichnete weichenstellung.
War ja ohnehin einige politprominenz unterwegs die saskia esken war ja auch auf dem kongress war die auch noch im kontext irgendeiner talks nicht zu sehen war nur da sozusagen hat sich informiert,
gut so mach das mal mal zu gibt eine menge.
Ich weiß nicht ob sie sich informiert hat oder lieber andere aber.
Nimm das jetzt einfach mal positiv an.
Nicht aber nimmt doping habe ich jetzt gemacht von daher passt schon gut dann machen wir jetzt hier mal klappe zu.
Wir ich würde noch gerne werner herzlich danken und frank.
Und ansonsten stellen sich ja viele die frage wie,
wir uns hier so dauerhaft finanzieren metaebene über spenden und im auto wollen wir dann einfach auch mal klären wo womit wir unsere miete bezahlen.
Wie es läuft was uns eigentlich abs.
Wo wir eigentlich nur unsere finanzielle unabhängigkeit her haben.
Insofern wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen tag bis bald.
Tschau tschau.